where there are about 25 000 refugees
but actually there are much more spread
across the border between Chad and Sudan
now we've been speaking to many people
here they're all have hiring accounts
and stories of violence especially in
cities not far from here and they all
are talking about inter-communic
violence between Arab groups against
Masala and we have been speaking with
Salma one of them who has lost her
father and who brought her during the
fighting
um
the vast majority of the people are
actually Sudanese who fled Western four
and now the UN agents have this huge
emergency of trying to relocate all of
these people from the border deeper into
the country for two main reasons one is
because the rainy season is coming and
by the end of June all of here there
will be rivers and so the people here
with the highly isolated and the second
reason is for security because fighting
is still ongoing just a few kilometers
away
foreign
[Music]